hallo mein name ist luca und vor einigen
tagen habe ich bereits auf den ersten
teil der hilfe folge lebensmittel machen
mich geil reagiert und habe euch dort
gesagt dass wenn das video 50.000 likes
bekommt reagiere ich ein paar tage
später auf teil zwei und das video als
70.000 likes und deswegen zerstören wir
heute mal wieder unsere gehirnzellen
zuschauer wie hartwich soll das noch
werden schauspieler ja wann werde ich
sterben gehirnzellen sind eh schon tot
ich kann die zukunft voraussehen luca
läuft wieder klatschen durchs zimmer
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
erika wir lieben lebensmittel las ich
auch meine damen und herren das ist
fremdscham pur lieber luca wenn du das
hier liest dann versuche bitte nicht
schon bei der hälfte vom hausdach zu
springen liebe grüße sarah dankeschön
für die lieben grüße und wir schauen uns
jetzt mal direkt das video an
ich schaue dass ich an mayonnaise oder
was ist das
[Musik]
schaut euch einen blick an
an alle die neu dazu gekommen sind das
ist lars und glas lieb lebensmittel mehr
als alles andere was soll das denn
werden die fertig sind die sehen ja was
ist das tut mir leid ich muss euch diese
wird da ja immer so ein bisschen aus
bieten so geil wie ja da sagt habe ich
da viel besser gezeigt das sieht ja aus
wie kraut und rüben da gefallen mir die
platten von oz zehnmal besser du bist
ein zweiter ja
o
der der lobpreis zeigt sich mal zusammen
der chef sich ganz schön zu mögen ich
habe auch auf die
ok
der chef scheint dir ganz schön zu mögen
ich habe ein auge auf dir sprachenlernen
ich habe mal auf die es geht wieder los
reiß dich zusammen alles nichts
obwohl du bist schon geil
ja eine standard
die man mit seinem käse führt die musik
wieder los und die stimme mein gott
fantast
so zart und wird sich das würdest du
eine [ __ ] machst du schon wieder
probleme oder war dieses alten sie ist
ja alles mit einem käppi und die schürze
und mädchen schnitten oktober ein foto
o
ich weiß nicht ob ihr
gerade gesehen habt ja motivator bahn
tolles foto auch hier werden wir zweite
der merkwürdigen mutter sohn beziehung
moni scheint eine richtige helikopter
mutter zu sein
wie kommt der mutter
wer kennt es nicht das ist die mode ist
dass wir jetzt hier einst diesen date
aus der letzten folge
[Musik]
butterbrot von letzter nacht lag da noch
menschlich oder ist das eine salami ist
ganz anders als die anderen nicht bisher
getötet habe stimmt gott was schaue ich
mir an durch das richtige frauen
ich
würde ich da mal aufs hausdach bewegen
schweiz bin zurück vom hausdach es geht
das nämlich so verpasst
harmonie die wäsche machen würde gar
nicht hier gott der das tut mir echt ein
bisschen leid
gott ist sogar im kühlschrank da wird er
doch bestimmt wieder irgendwas
entsetzter entdecken
die kräuterbutter 40 sich aufregen
aufregen kräuterbutter viele paare
nutzen lebensmittel um den erotik faktor
in ihrer beziehung zu erhöhen was
wer
was also ich will dieser hat therapeuten
psychologen keine ahnung was sie da
genau für eine rolle übernimmt wirklich
nicht zu nahe treten aber was nimmt
london in einer beziehung um das ganze
aufregender zu machen denkt sie wirklich
da kommen dann leute so an zum partner
und sagen so haben wir ein vegetarisches
mühlen hat guck mal hier mein
meerrettich ich habe hier noch eine
schale inc war
hey
ich habe mittlerweile angst vor allen
personen die dabei dabei gerade mein
gott oh mein gott du heilige mutter
gottes a
ich will es nicht mehr sehen ich dachte
der erste teil bei der reaktion auf
diese folge die ich vom portal
hochgeladen hat war schlimm und quinn
spur aber dann zersprengt in der arme
hände wenn ihr das sehen wollt was ich
gerade hier sehe dann schaut euch das
video ab minute 545 an
ich konnte euch hier gerade nichts
einblenden das wäre nicht werbe
freundlich gewesen
linkes in der video beschreibung ich
kann euch nicht empfehlen darauf zu
klicken das ist nicht wahr
er nimmt die kräuter buntenbach
ich kann natürlich weiter gucken mal
hilft mir das ist das richtige wort
gerade schaut euch das video gerne an
wenn ihr die szenen sehen wollt von
minute 5 45 bis 720 oder irgendwie so da
passiert all das was mich gerade so
verstört hat
ich hatte noch nie so einen moment in
einer hilf mir folge dass sich bei mir
alle haare aufgestellt haben und ich mir
gedacht habe ab geht's aufs hausdach und
wieder runter ihrig
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht ob ich das
komplett noch durchziehen kann schön
vorsichtig damit umgehen zieht ihr am
besten handschuhe
er muss jetzt schinken schneiden
der ton kommt der ton kommt langsam
[Musik]
so kleiner süßer unverschämter schinken
du prachtexemplare ich fasse es gar
nicht um ahlens nahrung in pi mal daumen
satz des pythagoras wieder mal was
schaue ich mir hier an ihr wisst ich
habe schon auf vielen schwachsinn auf
meinem kanal reagiert aber dass das
meine lieben freunde ist das schlimmste
das ist der absolute tiefpunkt ich kann
nicht in worte fassen wie sehr ich mich
gerade in fremdscham bade
startet man in fremdscham damit glas
definitiv einen schritt zu weit ja oder
100 seinen eigenen lebensmittel machte
seine sache aber diese lebensmittel
gehören seinem chef
er darf sie nicht einfach verunreinigen
oder sonstwie unbrauchbar machen
damit riskiert er die fristlose
kündigung konnte obendrein wird der
schadensersatz bezahlen müssen
lars ich geb dir jetzt hier im finalen
tipp also ist ja immer so meine
kommentare richte sich nicht gegen den
schauspieler sondern gegen die rolle von
daher lasse
[Musik]
da kann man mit tipps auch nicht mehr
weiterhelfen
anders hatte mich schon heute geht's mir
jetzt nicht so beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch meine reaktion hierauf
den zweiten teil von lebensmitteln
machen mich gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da schreibt mir mal gerne in die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet ich ja
das ist einfach meine lieblingsserie das
video hier geht es zwar noch sechs
minuten allerdings bin ich ganz ehrlich
mit euch freunde ich kann mir das nicht
weiter anschauen
ihr findet einen link zu der folge in
der beschreibung habe ich ja schon
gesagt und ist auch mein instagram
verlinkt dagegen heute ein neues bild
online es ging auch heute
selbstverständlich wie jeden tag seit
ein paar tagen eine neue podcast folge
online könnt ihr auch gerne
vorbeischauen dick und doof sandra und
ich quatschen über gott und die welt
wirklich nicht weiter anschauen aber
nicht einen kanal wenn ihr soll
qualitativ hochwertigen lernen
[Musik]